alors il ya jean dit mme ndour qui était
à côté de vous hassan qui est écrivain
et gérant d'un café littéraire à mais si
vous êtes passionné de culture vous
ouvrez un café littéraire en 2010 et
vous subissiez le racisme dès le début
les gens dénoncent un bar clandestin
alors que tout est en règle des hells
des odeurs de bouffe africaine alors
qu'il ne sert que des planches de
fromage et charcuterie de ce qu ils ont
senti l'odeur du bruit trop fort alors
que les gens lisent dans son dans votre
café votre local poubelles verrouillé
pour vous empêcher d'y accéder vous
recevez régulièrement des intimes des
insultes également de quel type
oui tout à fait ben justement je café
littéraire a été ouverte depuis le 14
juillet 2018 et mon idée au départ
c'était justement de l'appeler le m10 m
comme métissage culturel et is comme
tissage connexion des valeurs humaines
pour rejoindre ce que disais tantôt la
ministre
mais j'étais relativement plus ou moins
armé puisque tout ce qui touche au
logement j'ai eu affaire à ces à ces
problèmes là j'avais du mal à me loger
et même j'avais participé stick de sos
racisme ans à l'époque où j'avais moi
même appelé pour moi fait comprendre que
l'appartement était louée et une dame a
appelé une française mais ce qu'on avait
directement appelé exactement tout à
l'heure jan 10 20 tours alors je vous le
dis moi j'ai lu des choses sont
incroyables vous a dit rentre dans ta
tribu on ne veut pas de noirs ici est
donc effectivement je faisais des
paroles relativement assez blessantes à
ce que quand ça touche à votre déni
dignité à votre être à vos racines
avoirs d'origine ça fait extrêmement mal
et au delà de ça déjà quand j'ai ouvert
un café littéraire ça fait bizarre au
noir qui ouvre un café littéraire où
j'organise des rencontres littéraires
les cafés philo une dictée mensuel du
théâtre tous les mois on évite tous les
deux minutes de la ville de metz qui
viennent manger gratuitement 20 à 30
personnes
avec ses quelque part c'était un peu ma
part 2 de la france que j'aime bien mais
effectivement on m'a fait comprendre une
fois au monsieur qui s'arrête dit mais
c'est trop le bordel chez vous je dis
mais quel bordel je lui ai dit mais
c'est une rencontre littéraire rené
monsieur un dg pamela votre communauté
il faut alors que le soir là mais moi
j'étais le seul noir bizarre moi parce
que je le remercie affecté mois toutes
les personnes qui me vous vouliez que la
culture soit réduite nyon entre entre
les
religion et en fait ça s'est retourné
contre nous ça s'est retourné contre moi
malheureusement et c'est vrai que
j'arrive le matin vos boîtiers fracassé
j'arrivais plus accéder je paye mes
charges comme tout le monde tous les
soirs on mettait une chaîne au local
poubelles pour que je pense que oui le
café littéraire il est toujours ouvert
ça a eu beaucoup de mal j'ai été étonné
cgu de soutien de ses pouvoirs à la
question la france est elle raciste
il ya beaucoup de racisme sert
d'hacienda c'est viscéral
mais tous les français ne sont pas
racistes pascal si aujourd'hui je tiens
encore le café littéraire c'est aussi
beaucoup à cette diversité a beaucoup de
blanc si je peux m'exprimer ainsi qui
m'ont soutenu et qui qui constitue l de
90 à 95 pour soi de de ma clientèle
mais le problème aussi quelque part
c'est que malheureusement on l'a
souligné tantôt aussi bien au niveau des
médias aussi bien au niveau des
politiques qui a pas assez de
représentativité parce que le noir c'est
tout de suite celui qui nettoie la rue
l'arabe c'est tout de suite le jour de
photos le rappeur est donc le juif
quelque part mais c'est tout de suite
personne qui a l'argent donc cesser le
type ces clichés il n'y a pas de combat
par rapport à ça et quelque part on n'a
pas de représentativité de noirs ou
d'arabes qui ont peut-être réussi qui
peuvent montrer l'exemple
alors qu'en interne à la maman coud et
d'autres malheureusement y ont pas ils
n'ont pas forcément de tribunes ou alors
des médecins ou des avocats qui peuvent
participer à certaines à certaines
tribunes et montrer aux jeunes et aux
jeunes générations montrer aux jeunes
des cités convoi y a pas que le foot le
foot c'est bien le foot on pourrait ici
c'est honorable la france black blanc
beur ou la phrase de ma p o qui revenait
c'était une beauté on était tous content
mais il ya aussi d'autres exemples et
ces exemples on doit quand même pouvoir
les mettre en avoir été ils doivent être
plus visible est ce qu'on va utiliser
alors une somme allant dans la rue on a
demandé aux passants nous dire quel
mouleur venait en tête quand on leur
parle et de la communauté noire regarde
moi j'irai un peu de discrimination
attirer
entre puissances comme jordan
difficultés là
6 mhz / population car il y en a
beaucoup
on a parlé franchement il n'y a que ça
voilà c'est voilà on entend des voix là
des choses assez hallucinante 1 comme
vous dites alors christine kelly juste
gérer votre avis avant d'avoir karim
aussi et bien sûr tous les autres qu'est
ce que vous dites à cette question la
france est elle raciste
est ce que vous avez entendu là vous
avez vu on parle beaucoup des médias je
me tourne vers vous parce que vous étiez
au csa mine de rien c'est ça à ma
fonction à donner voilà il paraît
qu'elle est descrimination parler de
discrimination positive on en a
longtemps parlé dans les médias où il
fallait mettre plus de communauté
invisible à l'antenne c'est vrai qu'il
ya des quotas à respecter moi j'ai
entendu je vous le dis j'ai entendu
plein de fois d'aider les patrons de
chaînes dira non il faut mieux m il vaut
mieux mettre un noir là parce que sur le
quota c'est mieux il vaut mieux mettre
une femme parce que c'est mieux on n'a
pas assez de femmes à l'antenne locale à
rabat les choses dans les emplois j'ai
déjà entendu je vous le dis moi je dis
la vérité et j'ai entendu j'ai fait
plein de chouettes donc à vous de
trouver voilà où ils avaient en effet
plongé fait le groupe france télé j'ai
fait le groupe m6 j'ai fait le groupe
tf1 je vois là j'ai fait j'ai fait le
bon sens et les gens ne font pas le
courage de dire aux hommes qui sont pas
assez bons et leur disent c'est pas
parce que t'es pas bon c'est parce qu'on
a besoin d'un quota oui mais en tout cas
moi moi moi quand j'entends moi moi la
discrimination positive par exemple dans
les médias elle me dérange parce que je
pense que les personnes doivent être là
pour leurs talons ils ont choisi une
femme c'est pour son talent
si on choisit une personne de couleur
c'est parce qu'elle est du talon et
c'est parce qu'elle ya bien à la place
où le world wide web
non ça avance voilà exactement si on
verra mais je vous le dis à solibra moi
j'ai vu des directeurs de programmes de
chaînes faire leur grille avec mon alors
on a combien donc on a bon c'est bon là
on a deux noirs on a six femmes
on a cinq arabe tient on à un juif ouais
mais deux juifs quand même ça serait
bien si on fait pas ça les dossiers
n'avancent pas moi aussi je change
d'avis toutes les semaines à ce sujet
sur la discrimination positive me dis
c'est pas juste parce que ça devrait
être sur la grille mais si on fait juste
ce critère ça n'avancera jamais y aura
jamais plus d'arabes plus de noirs plus
de femmes dont assez dérangeant ses
carnets normes problème mais au lit dans
les regards des carnets en plus
ils conscience qu'il fallait faire de la
discrimination là bas c'est ça oui mais
c'est grave poussée christine le conseil
suggère de répondre à celle 120 minutes
de gens jeunes inquiète pas non mais tu
vas voir une large plage
franchement tu seras extrêmement
présents comme karim inquiète pas non le
csa ça fait des années que le sait ça se
bagarre pour avoir justement de la
diversité à la télévision pour avoir une
soci de télévision qui ressemble à la
société elle se bagarre moi je comptais
l'hypocrisie là dedans non laissez moi
terminer mon cher cyril le csa se
bagarre et fait face justement à cette
barrière de beaucoup de patrons de
chaînes deux responsables qui doivent
embaucher et qu'ils disent oui oui on va
fair en affaires et qui finalement ne
font pas regardons effectivement on
commence à se serait-il mme depuis des
années le csa se bagarrent effet
justement une sorte de comptabilité et
et tente de la faire même s'il ne faut
pas faire de comptabilité ethnique pour
pouvoir pousser les chaînes à avancer
les chaînes télévisées mais aussi les
radios
alors malheureusement on se rend compte
en tout cas quand j'étais au csa que
c'était une sorte de combat permanent
pour arriver à convaincre effectivement
une chaîne un média un patron une
émission de représenter simplement ce
qu'on voit effectivement dans la société
parce que ça c'est n'importe quoi je
vais en tony kavanagh qui est un ami
voilà moi je me rappelle il était sur
france télé et il paraît que toutes les
semaines ils faisaient des émissions il
est un concours de danse et un petit peu
voilà comme danse avec les stars
à l'époque il paraît que toutes les
semaines et à le directeur des
programmes qui venaient le voir qui lui
dit faire attention parce que mine de
rien et reste faudrait peut-être les
coupes et j'aimerais bien que telle et
les cheveux coupés frais la semaine la
semaine d'après mais attention là la
semi ouvert que l'on voit trop ton corps
c'est peut-être un petit peu gênant
après la boucle d'oreille et trouver
toutes les semaines il trouvait des
excuses parce que l'émission marchait
pas et en fait ils pensaient que c'est à
cause d' anthony kavanagh et un moment
anthony kavanagh le niveau dis moi ce
qui me dérange c'est que je suis noir en
fait c'est toute une seule animateurs
noir sur france télévisions moi je vous
le dis il ya une époque et on me l'a dit
combien de fois on m'a dit il faut tout
raser la barbe
il faudrait que tu sois moins brun un
moment il ya même un directeur du
programme qui a dit anna ça marchera
jamais l'humour couscous boulette ça
marchera jamais en france c'est du vrai
bat donc pour vous dire que voilà c c
dans l'air
pas on va pas se mentir